[Musique]
les
allemands
dans ma famille d'alex à clipser
j'aimerais le sentent obligés sur
palerme dr bakary dr la série le tapis
montataire des
leurs
le territoire oqtf
isolement que son plan de bataille
l'opération
a pour but de
mettre fin
la correction de la semaine
le petit d'en faire que possibilité de
synthés des shows donc on va et c'est
pour cette raison qu'on va arrêter et 10
heures
la population pénible
vous alors qu'en tunisie ça fait 50 ans
que les municipalités tirs sur les
chiens errants pensant que c'est une
solution pour gérer le problème de
prolifération des chiens or on sait très
bien que ça ne sert à rien que c'est
inhumain qu'on veut nous ce qu'on
réclame et à travers même une loi qui
impose aux municipalités de créer des
centres de gestion des chiens errants et
bien on demande aux murs toutes les
municipalités de faire un centre de
stérilisation il y en a déjà cinq en
tunisie donc c'est la bataille on a
gagné une bataille n'a pas encore gagné
la guerre